فنقلت صحيفه واشنطن بوست الامريكيه عن
مصادر داخل تويتر قولهم ان الموقع اصبح في
وضع حرج وسط تساؤلات حول قدرته على
الاستمرار بالعمل واكدت صحيفه ان تويتر
شهد مئات الاستقالات بعد مطالبه ايلون
ماسك الموظفين بزياده ساعات العمل كان من
ضمن المستقلين مهندسون بارزون الامر الذي
يهدد عمل المنصه حيث تعرضت انظمه الموقع
الحساسه لمشكله اثر الاستقالات واكدته
واشنطن بوستن سياسيين وحكومه وسفارات
يستعدون للاسوء في حال تعطل تويتر مؤقتا
ابلغت منصه التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر
موظفيها بان مباني مكاتب الشركه ستغلق
مؤقتا وبان هذا القرار سيسري على الفور
اعلان ياتي وسط تقارير عن استقاله اعداد
كبيره من الموظفين
اما
البقاء التي تصرفاته هكذا خاطب الملياردير
الامريكي الماسك موظفه في منصه تويتر
للمضي قدما في بناء تويتر من جديد والنجاح
في عالم يتزايد التنفس سنحتاج الى ان نكون
متشددين للغايه هذا يعني العمل لساعه
طويله بكثافه عاليه
العصفور الازرق
الجديد فان لم يكن هناك مجال للحوار
وابداء الراي طريق الاستقاله كان اسهل
واقصر تقارير عده تشير الى ان مئات من
الموظفين قد استقالاتهم ونسبه كبيره منهم
كانوا من المهندسين المسؤولين عن صيانه
الخدمه في موقعه تويتر
التداعيات المتسارعه التي تشهدها منصه
تويتر مثلت زوبعه بداها ماسك بسلسله
تغييرات وقرارات تسببت بفوضه داخليه
للشركه انتقل صداها خارجيا لمستخدمي
المنصه بدات بطرد 50 من الموظفين الذين
كان يبلغ عددهم
7,500 شخص والغاء سياسه داخليه كانت تسمح
بالعمل من المنزل وفرض ساعات عمل طويله
الملياردير الامريكي بدا اخيرا بالشعور
بمالات خياراته القاسيه ليعلن ان جميع
المباني مغلقه مؤقتا ويمنع دخول جميع
الموظفين اعلان عزاهم موقع بزنس انسايدر
الى مخاوف الملك الجديد للشركه من احتمال
حدوث تخريب داخلي واضطرابات
لكن قرار الموظفين المباغته بالاستقاله
دفع ماسك للاجتماع مع مجموعه من العمال
الذين اعتبرت ادوارهم حاسمه في محاوله
الاقناعهم بالبقاء وفق صحيفه نيورك تايمز
هجره العقول المحركه لموقع تويتر انتقلت
ايضا لبعض مستخدمين منصه الذين بداوا
بالفعل في توديع تويتر وسط توقعاته بمشكله
تقنيه ضخمه تعصف بانظمه تويتر
لقرابه 16 عاما روان حمزه العربيه
معنا من الرياضه المحرر التقني في صحيفه
عربيه عبدالله السابع اهلا فيك عبد الله
مره جديده على شاشه العربيه كتبت على
تويتر في حسابك منذ عشر ساعات بعض
الحسابات اصبحت تروج انه تويتر راح يتوقف
نهائيا الموضوع مو صحيح والحياه مستمره هل
لا زلت على رايك وعلامه بنيه
اول شيء يعطيكم العافيه على هذه الاستضافه
بخصوص موقع تويتر والمشاكل اللي قاعد يمر
فيها حاليا اتوقع الناس تويتر راح يستمر
الناس ما دفع 44 مليار دولار على شان يغلق
المنصه او تكون فيها مشاكل همم تويتر
حاليا تمر مرحله التغيير جدا كبيره فمراحل
التغيير تتطلب همم مراحل مختلفه وايضا
تتطلب باستغناء عن بعض العقول القديمه
اللي موجوده في المنصه يمكن من حسن حظ
تويتر ان ااه الاستقالات اللي حدثت هذه
الفتره همم تمت باقالات ثانيه من الشركات
كلنا عارفين ان كل الشركات فتره الماضيه
قالت عدد كبير الموظفين فهناك عدد كبير من
الموظفين حاليا يحلمون بعدد من الوظائف
فلذلك تويتر راح تكون قادره على تعويض
الموظفين المستقيمين
ساعات عمل طويله وهم يعترضون على ذلك
لماذا هذه الخطوات التي يعتبروها البعض
متسرعه جدا لماذا لا يامن نفسه بفريق عمل
قبل ان يقدم على هذه التغييرات الان هو
خائف من احداث خرق في المنصه ومن الصحيح
لكن لازم نعرف شيئا لهم ماسك عند شركات
داعمه راح تكون مستمره بالدعم له فعلى
سبيل المثال هو اول ما جاء الى منصه تويتر
جاب مهندسين من تسلم
بالامكان اذا واجه اي مشكله في اعداد
الموظفين انه يستعير موظفين من الشركات
الكثيره اللي يملك اللي يمتلكها بجانب
توظيف مهندسين جدد من الاستقاله ومن
امازون من استقاله ومن مايكروسوفت من
الاستقالهم من شركات كثيره فاكيد لو في
موظف جالس في بيتهم ما عنده اي دخل حاليا
لكن تيجي تعطيه عقبه وظيفه بساعات اطول
راح يفضل الوظيفه بساعات اطول على الجلوس
في المنزل فلذلك اتوقع انه من حسن الى
الناس المشاكل اللي صار في فتره حاليا
جاءت بفتره اقالات كثيره من الشركات
المنافسه اللي موجوده في السوق فيسبوك
قالت اكثر من 11,000
عاجز عن ايجاد 500 موظف من الناس
الاستقاله من الشركات الموجودين بجانب من
استعانه من الشركات اللي موجوده عند اتوقع
ان الموضوع مصعب بجانب جيده بس البعض
يعتبر انه نقطه ضعف منه انه اضطر بعد كل
هذه الاستقالات الى الاجتماع ببعض
الموظفين الذين يعتبرون يعني غير قادر على
الاستغناء عنهم فبالتالي يبدو انه هذا
يوضح انه قد يكون تسرع
اول ما جاء للمنصه احد التغيرات جدا كثيره
احدث مشاكل موجوده في المنصه يمكن ما كان
عارف حجم المنصه قوتها والشغلات اللي ممكن
تاثيرها فمثلا موضوع التوثيق المباشر بدفع
مبلغ 10 دولار هذا سبب مشاكل سبب مشاكل
لشركات موجوده في سوق الاسهم والسبب ازمات
وتم ايقاف مثل هذه الميزه فتوقع انه الى
الناس كان جاي بتسرع بقرات جدا سريعه في
المشاكل التي
اتوقع انه راح تخليه اكثر
على اصدار اي قرارات خلال الفتره همم
المستقبليه في المناصه من الناحيه التقنيه
بتتوقع ان هؤلاء الموظفين يكون عندهم
القدره على احداث يعني على التعرض لانظمه
الموقع الحساسه لكي يقع تماما ما اتوقع ان
في احد عنده القدره او عند القدره عشان
يسبب مشاكل واكيد في موظفين عندهم القدره
وعندهم همم شغلات من هذا النوع لكن ما راح
يدخل نفسه في مشاكل قضائيه وملحقات
قانونيه لان القانون اكيد راح يكون يحاسب
مثل هذه الموظفين لان في مشاكل مرتين في
شركات كثيره خلال فتره الماضيه تم ايقاف
موظفين واقالتهم ويسببت تعويضات كبيره
للشركات في اي موظف عندها القدره على
احداث خرق قانوني اتوقع انه احرص شخص انما
يسبب مشاكل لان ممكن يقع في مشاكل قانونيه
مشاكل جدا كثيره في حياته ممكن تعويضات
كثيره من الصوت وغيرها من الشغلات
المختلفه عبد الله لديك مليون و300,000
متابع على تويتر هل انت من المطالبين ايضا
بدفع ثمانيه دولارات للابطاء على الاشتراك
وهل ستفعل ذلك والله اتوقع انه لو ماسك رح
يبدا يطلب من الناس اللي مستقيم في الفتره
السابقه لم يدفعون مبالغ الاشتراك لاضافه
مميزات جديده موجوده عندهم في مميزات
[ضحك]
لا يعني اتوقع
ين من الدفع هم رؤساء الشركات ايضا
الرؤساء الدول الشركات الرسميه وغيرها من
الشخصيات المهمه لكن البقيه اتوقع ان
يكونوا فيمنها من دفع مبالغ لتويتر للحفاظ
على التوثيق وايضا اضافات مميزات جديده زي
ما حصل في سناب شات سناب شات امتلك عدد
متابعين فيه اكثر من تويتر لكن عشان احصل
على بعض المميزات انا ادفع حاليا بشكل
شهري عشان احصل على مميزات موجوده في
الملف هل تتخيل العالم بدون تويتر لو توقف
اتوقع
التواصل اجتماعيه كانت موجوده وضخمه وكانت
موجوده نجاحات كثيره وينها الان اختفت لا
تدوم الدنيا لاحد شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه التقنيه في صحيفه عربيه عبد الله
السبع من الرياض
ومع الاخبار المتداوله حول تويتر
واحتماليه انتهاء مسيرتها في عالم التواصل
الاجتماعي كان للمغربين كلمتهم ايضا من
خلال رسوم عداد
[موسيقى]